Southern Nevada is a buzz tonight with
stories about the crash of an unknown
object and the alleged sighting of
strange creatures in the backyard of a
Northwest Valley home so
it was like that eight news now
investigator David charns reported about
how Metro Police responded back on May
1st after receiving a strange call from
a very frightened family well our report
generated a Global Response and now
piecing together the sequence of events
has been kind of tricky in part because
the primary Witnesses have been almost
as elusive as the beings they say they
encountered Chief investigator George
Knapp is as perplexed as the rest of us
George as you know this is not our first
UFO Rodeo we first heard about the
incident in early May via the Metro
Police Grapevine the incident has a lot
in common with other bizarre cases from
around the world an alleged crash
strange beings and bits and pieces that
don't make sense but the police took
this seriously and so do we
just before midnight on April 30th Sky
Watchers across several Western States
saw a bright Fireball streak through the
heavens a police officer working in the
Northwest Valley caught a glimpse of the
colorful object on his body cam at
nearly the same time a ring camera in
the area recorded a strange noise in
what sounds like a crash
one family living in a ranch-style home
had a much closer view of the object two
brothers and their father were working
on a vehicle in their yard when they
caught a glimpse of a sparkly object As
It Came Crashing Down then were hit by
what they describe as a shock wave one
of the witnesses a young man named Angel
has stated when the brothers looked into
the yard where the object landed that
spot was obscured and blurry as if by
unknown form of camouflage what they saw
next prompted a frantic call to 9-1-1 so
there's two
correct and they're very large
they're like gay food 9 feet 10 foot I
don't know like they look like aliens to
us
big eyes they have big eyes like like I
can't explain it and pick our mouth
their shiny eyes and
and they're not given the 100 they're
not human eight news now investigators
have spoken with family members multiple
times in the past four weeks but each of
the three times we accepted their
invitation to do an interview they
didn't answer the door or their phone
these are some of the claims they've
made in other public forums multiple
family members backed up the story in an
initial police report we obtained Angel
says they heard the patter of multiple
feet in the yard they later heard
footsteps on their roof they saw one of
the eight foot tall creatures climb
behind the controls of a large front
loader stored in the yard as if trying
to engage it he got a good look at one
of the creatures he said a greenish
grayish being with large eyes and Long
Legs he says he could hear its deep
breaths and when he locked eyes he was
in essence Frozen in place couldn't move
in the middle of the yard where the
object had crash then vanished a
circular impression was left in the soil
okay where is this on your property
Metro sources say the police dispatcher
initially wondered whether to send a
crisis intervention team to help the
troubled witness but then took the
incident seriously two officers arrived
38 minutes after the call and by then it
heard from other officers they proceeded
cautiously and managed some nervous
laughs I ain't dealing with that a few
days later the family says two Metro
sergeants returned to the scene to ask
follow-up questions the family says they
also saw men in suits and sunglasses
driving in a car with government plates
cruising slowly past the house in the
following days Nellis and Creech have
denied any interest or involvement with
the incident Metro has indicated they
believed the family that something
crashed in their yard but what
you mentioned George in that piece that
you know they were frozen because so
many people have been critical of like
why didn't get their phone out why
didn't they video do we know if there's
even any video of this incident yes and
no so there's a surveillance camera in
the backyard the property owner keeps
that because he's like got a lot of
expensive equipment there what we were
told is that at the moment this thing
comes down and crash this camera went
out and it was was out for a couple of
minutes when it came back on the object
was gone but the circle was there we've
been told by Angel in multiple phone
conversations that he shot video of the
creatures we haven't seen it and we
don't know anybody else who's seen it
yet so maybe he'll release it at some
point it's getting a lot of attention
yeah all over all right George thanks
for that